what is up reject nation look at this
funny little hair i got here we are
going to continue
superman in lois episode 12 i believe is
what it is
excited to check it out we are shooting
this at 5 30 in the morning
as loki is uploading you'll probably be
getting this on thursday
we just figured this would be the best
time to shoot it versus
us meeting up later tonight and really
throw her sleep schedule off it's
superman and lois i'm like well we gotta
cover it dude we gotta
do it it's superman absolutely so guys
if you could go ahead subscribe click
that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction for superman lowest is up also
if you go and hit that like button it
really helps us out in the algorithm
would really very much appreciate that
and of course full length watch along
where you stick up with the time code
for superman lois or over at our patreon
page and we cover a whole bunch of shows
there we're at the same tier you get the
option for both
reaction highlights and watch along
included and um
big thanks to pratham jindal that's the
one for editing the highlights
he's a good guy he's a good guy i think
he's a good guy
sure is the one who's editing he's not
sure about him he's the one who's
helping us head to the house yeah
let's do this
[Music]
john it's happening just like you said
it would
oh poor clark come on buddy
fight as long as you can not even
superman is strong enough to resist the
will of zod
well was i right it wasn't right i got
so many more kryptonite bullets
oh
such a good show i gotta go downtown for
a
mandatory military check-in please don't
die this season kyle
i know i want a redemption arc full-on
look i overheard some of the guys
talking this morning knowing you were
coming in david ramsey's guest starring
maybe just take a few days give people a
minute to cool off
damn it makes sense people losing their
faith in kyle
dad said that he could hear all of the
the fluctuations and the collective
sonic frequency
yeah but he also said that it took years
of training at the fortress in order to
do that
jordan you could do it but you had to
believe you could do it
at this great person touched my heart so
much
so
to save this world i need to put him
down i wish he didn't say david ramsey
was guest starring that kind of ruins
okay the more time that passes the
greater the odds are that he's gone
he won't be turned he will eventually no
he won't and i will prove it
god i love you lois
how far can you hear no i don't know oh
look at that focus
i can't tell the accents part regardless
it doesn't matter i couldn't hear that
whoa
i was the only one with powers who could
have done something and i just i didn't
you do something now
instead of the out rocket power
projectile is designed to completely
deplete our kryptonian's power
for how long forever
i used it in my fight against calo the
plan was to draw him deep into space
fire he thought i was running but
i wasn't before i saw if it worked
if we would end this once and for all we
should do the same thing here
okay tell us the superman yes you're
doing
wait hey i i made a mistake okay the
only
mistake made was all of us trusting you
oh
man oh no it wasn't your fault
no it's not it's your fault
damn it anything you can tell me about
what it was like
being a subject even if it seems
insignificant
i i couldn't remember things that i
couldn't picture my family
and it hurt should have pushed through
it
but you could fight back yeah so but
there was this
overwhelming sense that my family would
just be better off
if i just you know almost did
friday clerk i'll be long now father
come on dude
[Music]
oh man jordan where are you the badlands
i need to go right now okay oh come on
yes oh there he is diggle
diggle what are you doing here is argus
helping with the search
i assumed you knew your father called
lyla needed some tech delivers so
she sent me he looks so good in this
film quality wow
i thought you were on my side lois it's
just a precaution no decisions have been
made god
you can't try to kill superman you sure
as hell can't use argus tech to do it
the tech is mine
mom i need to talk it's important
don't tell all them yeah oh does diggle
have the green lantern ring my god
oh no they attacked our home
it's a good thing that no one was home
yeah well what if someone had been lana
okay
no look okay all we did is try and help
look
what those people think they're wrong
and they will figure it out
okay damn look edge edge told jordan
that
if anyone went looking for dad it
wouldn't be him they'd find boys you've
done great work here
can you give your mom and me a minute
i'm gonna nuke your husband
you need to understand honey i don't
have a team equipped to take on numerous
kryptonians and win
i have to shift my priorities make the
same decision i would if it were anybody
else
if there's even a one percent i'm
sending john
in but if tickle is a lantern now
[Laughter]
our superman is different but he would
never turn on humanity
it's a great reaction the reason i know
how much superman loves humanity
he is the love of my life
john superman is my husband
rick clark kent is superman
so i gotta kill one of your kids too
i don't have to kill you do i i need you
to believe the possibility that there's
hope
if that's what you need then you called
the wrong guy
no i have a responsibility to do the
right thing i am telling you that
killing superman is not the right thing
i fought beside him he's the best we
have oliver would have said that hell
they all would have
over i can't imagine the courage it took
for you to survive whatever the hell it
was that got you here but you're going
to need that courage today
or we'll be praying you make the right
call come on john
henry irons
okay try that
come on are you kidding
we absolutely can fix this it's just
going to take a little bit of paint
thinner and uh
good old american muscle
what i have feeling something terribles
about that i know oh
well well would you look at that and
there it is
this is my favorite sweatshirt
[Laughter]
let's all go this abuse from smallville
is the best thing that could have
happened
we should have been ostracized from the
town a long time ago
i told you cal no one can fight forever
no now we can move towards completing
what we came here to do
oh
holy [ __ ]
superman
oh god wow
talk to him boy he won't stop what's
coming
none of you can stop this
all right let's go
no you can't beat him you have to make
him remember who he is
he's fighting he's fighting he's
fighting
[Music]
oh
still in there i promise you can get
through to him
oh i can't stop
oh god clark
lois sent me to help you she still
believes in you
i met your boys
that pain you feel right now that is
nothing compared to what happens if you
lose them
right now fight back damn it
[Music]
kryptonians may be strong but i got
family okay take him
take him straight put him over your
shoulder make him home straight him
oh [ __ ] no man the heart on this show
[Laughter]
we got him
a smile too first you and i are gonna
deal with morgan edge
you and i yeah
father we can still next time you had
one mission and veers from us
because you're weak now go
and complete what you were sent here to
do
or know that you are the sole reason
krypton
was lost wow you're a shitty dad you're
a terrible dad
goodbye father
oh look at him superman of steel sidebar
hell yeah hell yeah
[Music]
you could have ruled with me as my
brother
instead i will bury you in the ashes of
this world
[Music]
[Laughter]
so much heart
lois you saved the day
all you guys they're all they're all
heroes in my book
are they good it's all his idea we were
just trying to think what would you do
lois
[Music]
morgan edge is in a state-of-the-art
military prison he's never gonna hurt
anyone again
you to stay for dinner i order a mean
takeout
i'll wrap things up with your dad
besides family time is sacred
and you guys are definitely do unless
you got jobs attended
bring it in come on it's about
family so leslie lara is still
in the wind at this point she doesn't
really have a next move
finding her is our number one priority
i'm proud of you when the chips were
down you still had faith
that's what made the difference lois
lane you're the [ __ ]
you're the best of us lois
maybe yeah i mean that's i can see that
for sure
all those voices and stuff made it sound
that way yeah it's getting caught part
of your plan
it's crazy to take a break from this
show not by our own choice
but take a break from this show and come
back here and
this feels like this should have been
the episode
it took a break i know it's like it's so
climactic
and it's such a culmination of so many
plot threads
yeah this seems like the one you would
take a break on um
but i know there's a whole bunch of
behind the scenes reasoning
for why they did it you know i believe
the pandemic really affected their
shooting schedule in a lot of ways
yeah and then i think also just the warm
reception of the show got them
slightly they got their season extended
a little bit or something like that so
oh really yeah i believe so yes uh if
i'm
correct about that uh you can clear me
out down below if not but i believe
that's what i heard so you kind of have
both
that lights on oh good thanks for
telling me yeah i think at least what i
remember hearing is they got more
episodes
just given how you know big of a success
the show has been so far and how good
the word of mouth has been and then yeah
they were also delayed
due to it which shall not be named i'm
gonna
shout out a channel here really quick
high top film so i've shot it out before
but he recently did a video essay on
superman and lois
and uh if you guys are fans of this show
give it a watch it's
you'll you'll if you're fans of the show
you'll
he he puts it into the best words
possible
for why this show is so fabulous in
every
every sense second he said he was doing
that video i was waiting for it to
yes yeah uh because the heart of this
show
the cw especially in the early seasons
for many of their shows have such a
great
grasp of the heart and this one does it
in the way that's
the most impactful and the least cheesy
which i think they do they excel at that
um in every which way
and this episode in particular all
relied on the power of love
it's like you say it it sounds corny as
[ __ ] it doesn't it but
then you watch it you're like well
that's what this all came down to his
hope and love
what the power of the belief in good
like it's all such
beautiful things that save the day
and the heart of this show is like this
is a true to me this is the
very true superman and lois episode
when everyone's doubting it it was only
lois and the kids
right who are the only ones who are like
no you don't know him like we know him
yeah he can get through this and i loved
like john henry irons his turn through
that and i liked how it seemed
you know it was a one-two combo of lois
and jonathan
but it seemed like the the cherry on top
was jonathan absolutely
a kid the son the child of like
he knows what's like to lose a kid and
for the idea of a kid not having his
father
all these things kind of seeping into
his brain for that moment and having
those little visual moments of when you
see him fighting and the fact that he
was
what i loved was that when he's fighting
clark clark
is willing to sacrifice himself and i
think that speaks volumes to him
oh absolutely yeah i feel like that's
part of the linchpin is yeah he's still
thinking of the good of humanity even in
that moment when it looks like he's
about to be taken out you know for a
necessary means and that's such a crazy
that's such a great scene
like the action and it was so cool it
was just awesome to see steel visually
realized
and you know for further daylight fight
scenes that was the best looking
daylight fight
i think they've done yeah i could be
wrong about that but it looked flawless
like it's top-tier quality
visual effects design and um yeah john
henry irons this term was great
lois to me is just the star of this
episode
in more ways than one just because of
that
like i love how desperate she gets and
how till the very even when
superman's turned and she he's fighting
john henry irons
they'd do that shot where it's kind of
like this detached disarray
moment where you know that there's the
ringing the
blur vision behind her like oh my god
it's actually happened but she still
fights on through
oh it's so inspiring yeah it's so
inspiring it's inspiring as [ __ ]
it's like holding on for one more moment
just one more moment
yeah don't give up hope one more moment
and it's that hope that really kept
that that kept everything in check that
saved the day and
yeah i mean it
i'm so surprised by this because with
the cliffhanger of the last one you
think
again this show these might lead you to
think it was gonna be like a crazy ass
episode the next one
but they just managed to take their time
again and make it a really good
character focus and make it about the
emotion
more than anything else even bringing in
john diggle
um do you know diggle is i i vaguely
recognize him from seeing episodes over
your shoulder of what he's an arrow and
yeah he was like he was the main
supporting character in arrow
uh main male supporting character to say
the least and he was like oliver queen's
number one guy okay just the basic
summation of it and always
like even when they had disputes he was
always the guy who was the main the main
dude
back oliver okay um i mean there's some
wiggle room here because there's so many
seasons there were times they had real
fallouts and everything
but for all intents and purposes right
hand man yeah and then and then
with the way arrow ended there was a
moment that's why i thought it was
saying green lantern where
where he picks up a box and that's why
what he was referring to here
where it's green so it's like oh my god
he's gonna become green lantern cool
uh but i i guess not maybe jeff jones
no we're not doing that that's my new
job is to step in and go no lantern
nope no lancers no kryptonian
all the kryptonians um
yeah like it bringing in john diggle
what i was kind of concerned when i
when he was when he showed up was that
he was going to be a character who saves
the day
like let's bring in this guy from the
arrowverse nostalgic character
from the thing that launched aeroverse
yadda yadda yadda
maybe he's lantern now boom comes in
kicks some ass gets through superman i'm
like oh man why'd you
like the one with a side character yeah
which for me would have been cool
just because i love john diggle and but
if you ain't seen that show it's gonna
feel real
out of left field just within the
context of the show itself
it's like that would lose some of the
emotional weight and take away from some
of the characters here
clearly like if you if they did that
this the impact of these characters
would hold so much less weight
but i like how they brought him in there
as the to serve the role that he served
that one of the
roles he served best on arrow was like
oliver
i know you don't believe in yourself
you're doing a great job yeah you're
checking ass
you have a lot of heart man come on
you're a good guy despite what you say
you're a good guy and good hype man for
him to come in and say
that um like he's a hero he's one of the
best
he you should number one priority should
be saving him not
killing him you know uh okay i love how
they brought him in to serve that role
like yeah add weight to the
argument to the debate yeah it's like
argus is
it is like uh uh argus
is uh for like a [ __ ] um what's her
name amanda waller
uh oh it's like the suicide squad it's
like it's like
what is she oh i know i'm remembering
that correctly but it is am i
remember that incorrectly forgive me
guys we've been awake for 27 hours now
it's been a long day of wakefulness
so forgive my lapse in memory here um
but no it is like secret his wife lila
it's like secret government organization
okay not like super secretive but they
do a lot of secretive [ __ ]
you know so like manufacturing the
weapons and stuff
okay clandestine research and
development yes
so um having uh so i thought like that's
what it was gonna be about
but they didn't so i thought like the
writers made a really and david ramsey
did direct an episode earlier of this
season so perhaps i don't know maybe he
wiggled his way in here
that was his fee he was like you don't
have to pay me just you know let me
guest in one episode because like all
the
is about this show now it's so
interesting seeing him on like
from the crossovers to all of arrow yeah
and then seeing him here
like damn the quality of this show just
looks so much better
it's just stretched you know that
feeling when they adapt shows into
movies
and then the film quality is just like
so much freaking like damn this is weird
yeah that is kind of the vibe i got when
i was watching him
whoa you're like on film now this is
bizarre
as this tv character that i know um
anyway cw's really stepping it up anyway
yeah uh getting to that uh
yeah getting to the wrap around like
even with jonathan and jordan like
jonathan man the mvp he really is the
son of lois
uh jonathan uh you know motivating and
empowering and getting all the right
heart to hearts with everyone
yeah seriously he's like the emotional
secret weapons
for any conflict they're this close
though i will say they're this close to
um
uh general sam teetering on
caricature in the sense
of what i'm saying close i'm not saying
they're there that's why i
need to make that freaking clear because
they're playing it smart they're writing
it
just pitch at the right pitch where i
always understand why he's doing what
he's doing i always get it
but it's becoming to the predictable to
the point even though
but they have that ending note of like
i'll never doubt you again
there's just such a thing of like
knowing about the super superman
yeah it might be your husband uh but you
know we we got to prepare
yeah lois lois i know you disagree with
me and you're probably going to prove me
wrong in the end but no way i gotta get
my stockpile
tonight weapons still though that thing
that i you know my my ugly secret that i
disavowed a few days ago but now i'm
back online with
he's gonna have a hard-headed decision
where i'm gonna understand because of
his position at the dod
and his whole military background
experience with everything
uh but then he uh from the protagonist
standpoint you're like no
you're wrong you will be proved wrong by
the end of this episode most likely yeah
your approach while understandable is
not the one that's going to win the day
and like i said it's being done well and
with the ending note
that's like they were like they were
just a couple episodes away from making
it too repetitive for me
yeah i mean maybe it ends now it could
easily be the other kyle morgan edge
thing
but ultimately even that worked out in a
way that had nuance and weight and all
that sort of stuff so yeah it's like
even
whenever they teeter on yeah like you
said caricature i feel like
luckily thus far anyway they're good at
pulling back and resting on the nuance
which is good
yeah because like we said kyle they and
the whole family i'm glad they paid it
off in that way i mean that's such a
human reaction to house
a town people you know people in town
react to
like this is your fault we trusted you
we believed you you tricked us you like
they blame
they can't get the guy yeah they're
gonna blame the guy who got them
involved with the guy yeah they're gonna
blame the middle man and i mean i i
loved what that
became too because because we were
sitting there throughout the episode
going like
some some real terrible's about to
happen isn't it and and i i appreciate
when
things can play off that tension of you
kind of you know looking really hard at
what the visual language is saying or
whatever and expecting a shoe to drop
and and i feel like it does
it in a it almost creates like a reverse
tension
that really made those family moments
between them
that much more uh impactful too because
like
for the be one of the subplots of the
episode like you know it's
family stakes way smaller than what
we're dealing with just on the opposite
side with you know clark and everybody
but
even still i thought that was a very
heartfelt and a very real
struggle for them to deal with yeah the
town like you know and it's a
small town too so i'm not surprised
somebody like hurled a brick through
their window
well thematically them as the main b
story
uh compliment is is completely in line
runs parallel with the themes
of the main plot you know like they're a
family that
everyone is turning against and you know
they're being put down at every corner
but the thing that's
binds them keeps them strong together is
their love as a family that's the thing
that keeps them alive
you know because like kyle's this close
to losing it
i mean he does lose it a little bit but
you know like his wife
his lois i was grounding back into
like we have each other and that's what
counts and this will this will pass
we got our daughters and it's it is
i think it is a good call to have it and
have him suffer some
consequences for this level of
aggressive position
yeah like zealousness on behalf of this
guy
yeah um that was a great story in line
too like everything here was really well
fleshed out and the heart of it
uh just just was so swelling at every
turn
yeah it's funny to have watched this
after the loki finale just because in
totally different
ways they both had this quality where
they felt
really intense but also they both kind
of just hinged on
a lot of people debating what to what
the right way of handling a situation is
and what the consequences of handling it
wrong would be yeah
even though you could kind of see the
john henry irons turn coming yeah yeah
they didn't make it any less effective
no it still felt really cathartic and
and i mean when
they did yeah they freaking earned it
yeah really and i really
yeah and i appreciate that they bring it
right down to the wire and it's like
they're they're going to fisty cuffs now
you know it's it's at the point where
yeah clark is
begging him like please you gotta and
yeah having him take that moment to like
really see it john henry aren't really
see it in him and really make the choice
to try and pull it out of him the same
way
jonathan just did to him a few minutes
ago and then for them to team up against
the real bad guy he's also kind of
cathartic for like his
uh john henry iron still gets to do the
thing he's been saying he's going to do
yeah yeah yeah stop at kryptonians save
the world
stop a kryptonian from decimating
everything and killing lois lane again
and then maybe what's his name morgan i
just my god i keep forgetting it
taro taro maybe
is it taro is it maybe is it zazu
john keep the mic busy while i look it
up it is
uh what is this
music that you've got right now this is
youtube
this is perfect it's the uh uh
it's it's whatever his kryptonian name
is theme song
superman and lois you're so
close what did you think about the story
line with that here
that's one part that i felt was a little
lackluster uh
with uh with which part
although he does have a falling out with
his father and they are the bad family
yeah i mean that is or you know i mean
all his father does is just
feed him more and more disapproval he's
just like yeah you're such a
worse appointment you're gonna you're
gonna fail yeah you better go
do the final mission because you're a
failure and you'll always be a failure
and you deserve to be in pain
it says tall row tauro all right paul
row
tall row what did i say taro you got it
so much closer than i would have gotten
very close
yeah um yeah i mean i
i i thought that could have um used a
couple more extra beats
and not really i'm just looking for [ __ ]
to criticize
like you could you you could make the
relationship portrayed between morgan
edge and
his kryptonian father something a little
more nuanced than just like oh yeah your
hologram dad's really a bad
he seems like a bad guy and if you had
any better influences than this guy
and just you know all of the people who
found you being terrible maybe things
would have been different
other than plot development i felt like
his scenes were
kind of what we've already seen i mean
yeah he didn't get as much
like interesting or or nuanced things to
do in this episode he's mostly that's
there to keep taunting
clark yeah and to be like you you say
brother you're not my brother you were
ruling i'm like yeah i've heard you say
this before
you want to be brothers in an episode i
mean he's a crazy cliffhanger with him
because
because for what it's it seemed like it
was so painful from what he did and
and from the way they did that last
moment and their norman bait scene
seemed like there was just uh like
they're all living in him now
yeah and zod's gone apparently i mean
they said that he's just
gone for good yeah yeah
i'd be curious to see if that holds or
if they get an alternate dimensions
odd or something you gotta get zarya so
boys because yeah i mean as
as like as huge of a prospect it is to
be like oh damn he's gonna inhabit
clark's body
you know it also seems like uh it's a
really easy way to get rid of zod fur
yeah for all time pushed him out of his
mind yeah you just pushed him
out of sight out of mind no more zod
but yeah still guys great episode great
episode fantastic
really moving and uh yeah what'd you
guys think about it leave your thoughts
down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button thank you so much for being here
and hey let's do a patron of the day
shout out
andrew hayes man if there's anybody at
our patreon i could imagine being in the
exact
shoes of our favorite character kyle
it's you andrew hayes i could see you
being like oh man
you know my dad and i am going to save
the locksmith company we're the only
people in town who can help everyone get
back into their houses but everyone you
know businesses are failing and then
like a big rich dude moves into town who
seems dubious but hey
he's got the means to turn things around
of course you're gonna throw in with
them dude and everyone would trust you
because you're andrew hayes
you know you're a pillar of the
community you and your your family
business
dude thanks so much for being here
now that we're alone andrew i just
wanted to say
you're one of our oldest patrons and it
means a lot to me
i'm going to go to sleep now but as i do
i'm going to dream of you
and your wolverine hat
and locks the locks that you unlock
yeah i left this on